welcome back we like to stand up for the
little guys on the show and today that
means literally standing up for little
guys against Hugh Grant first he took
the sole role as an Umpa lumper in the
new Wonka movie depriving dwarf actors
of their chance at a coveted role and he
has had the audacity to whine about it
moaning about everything about the
facial cameras used by animators it's
like a crown of thorns he wailed very
uncomfortable I made a big fuss about it
I couldn't have hated the whole thing
more I sightly hate making films but are
lots of children and need money
meanwhile he said he's too old and fat
and ugly to star in romantic comedies
which is actually the first time he and
I have ever agreed about anything he's
ever said but returning to the show now
is Dylan pel is also known by his
wrestling ring name hnsw Dyan great to
have you back on uncensored I thought
about you immediately I saw Hugh Grant
moaning about the role that he played as
an Umpa lumper because not only did he
take a role that should have been for an
actor like like you but he then
complained about it what was your
reaction I don't I I fully don't
understand why he's complaining about it
he knew what he was getting into when he
accepted the role he he he obviously
knew so if there was any thought in his
mind that there would be uh backlash or
whatnot um even himself feeling that way
why take the role in the first place
whether it's the production crew uh
asking him to do the role he should have
then if there was any question of it
should have not accepted the role right
now the president of little people of
America Mark povinelli said the most
troubling aspect of the Hugh Grant
situation is that from what I can tell
they have CGM have the physical
attributes of a person with dwarfism
like the larger arms the shorter hands
so he looks like a person with
acondroplasia just like the OA Loompas
from the film of the early 70s they're
trying to maintain the physic Al ity of
dwarfism but erase the authenticity of
dwarfism which is troubling and that's
why you go well this is like a physical
version of blackface would you agree
with
that I I wouldn't go that
far um I have a condr plasia myself I
have a condr plasia myself uh this is
kind of going back to the the CGI or the
uh normal siiz actors in The Seven
Dwarves roles where it's taking roles
from um the dwarf Community from my my
community and giving them to average
size actors when those roles for my
community are very few and far between
so when roles like the Oompa Loompa or
the Seven Dwarves are really key roles
for people like me it's a it's really a
a kick in the guts and and it's a it's a
it's a hard pill to swallow it really is
and of course it comes to then I'm sorry
I was gonna say it's very hypocritical
for because we've seen time and again
Hollywood stars standing up and saying
only gay uh actors can play gay roles
only disabled actors can play disabled
roles uh only trans actors can play
trans roles and so on it seems like
you're the only group who do not have
Hollywood's protection in that
regard that's yeah I I just don't
understand
um especially now you're you're you're
spending the extra money on CGI and on
edits and all of that when there are
actors such as myself um and other
dwarves out there that would have loved
this role I'm sure um I would have loved
it obviously uh I'm I'm trying to do
more acting and more more roles whether
it be dwarf roles or normal size roles
so for me it would have been an absolute
dream rle um it's it's all in in
nowadays how it's viewed and I
understand completely how the Oompa
Loompas maybe have been viewed in
current day compared to in the past but
it's just I I I these are roles that
were made for people like me what is
your message to hug that he couldn't
have hated the whole thing more he said
asked if you if you like the final
product not really was it fun should
have been but it wasn't I hate making
films I just have lots of kids in need
of money he has got lots of kids by lots
of women probably does need the money
but it just it just struck me as being
just so dismissively cheap of him to do
that knowing the backdrop of the
controversy he knew what he was getting
into when he took the role that's that's
my whole thing he knew the character he
knew how it would be viewed edited and
all that but he still took it um he
that's where I don't really obviously I
have I have zero sympathy for him uh
feeling this way and it's it's even more
than that I just I feel it's a it's it's
it's a shame that he did take that role
because it could have went to someone in
my in uh in my of my stature well not
only somebody more appropriate frankly
but also somebody who would have
probably loved the role and celebrated
the role and talked about your joy at
playing that role in a movie of this
size it's an absolutely huge movie and
an absolutely huge part of the Wonka
story and backstory um how how they're
per you know perceiving it so for it to
go to a person in the dwarf Community
would have been absolutely enormous so
are we agreed then Dylan that he is
Hollywood's biggest
Wonker I
mean I I don't know about that I know
that I would have loved that role uh so
I would I I'll spare your normal size
roles yeah I'm gonna call him out I'm
calling him a Hollywood Wonka a gigantic
stature a massive siiz Wonka uh Dylan
great to have you back on the show thank
you very much thank you very much
talk